good morning Hank it's Wednesday and my
day went like this I got up at 5:30 a.m.
because apparently babies don't know
about time zones and Birmingham is one
hour behind Indianapolis even though
longitudinally they are basically
indistinguishable from one another which
is the kind of thing that really annoys
me at 5:30 in the morning
stupid time zones then I made some
coffee and felt better and then since I
was up I figured I might as well drive
down to my high school alma mater Indian
Springs school so my first novel Looking
for Alaska is about a guy from Florida
who is obsessed with the dying words of
famous people and then leaves home to go
to a boarding school in Alabama and I
myself was once a guy from Florida who
was obsessed with the dying words of
famous people and then left home to go
to a boarding school in Alabama ah
traffic jam it took me like half an hour
to get through this but you're gonna get
through it instantaneously anyway
looking for Alaska is fictional but the
setting really isn't the school in the
book is called Culver Creek but it is
almost inch for inch the same place that
Indian spring school was in 1995 so it's
always a little weird to go back because
there's the interstate exit and there's
sunny convenience kiosk and there's kusa
liquors where they cater to your
spiritual needs and here is the Swan and
the Octagon achill cafeteria and the
beautiful view from the classroom
windows and here is the swing where
Alaska and miles have their first
conversation where Alaska tells miles
the last words of Simone Bolivar dammit
how will I ever get out of this
labyrinth so it's still summer which
means no students and also that it is
hot like 103 degrees but just as they
say it isn't the heat so much as it's
the humidity actually it's also the heat
so the school was quiet in a way that it
never got during the school year and for
a minute I felt like I was walking
through a ghost town but then I realized
that I was the ghost there were only two
places I really needed to see so I
walked past the fancy new dorms and past
the student-run vegetable garden and
then down to the first place this bridge
of a Bishop's Creek in both Looking for
Alaska and real-life the concrete
outcropping beneath this bridge was
known as the smoking hole I could tell
that it had been a while since anyone
had been here because the briars had
grown into a tangle over the paths I
hadn't been down here in 15 years but it
looked the exact same as my memory
except with those cigarette butts maybe
I thought at first people just don't
smoke anymore which would be awesome but
then I started to worried that this slab
of rock had simply been forgotten that
there'd been a break in the secret line
of communication that handed down the
smoking hole from one generation to the
next and that made me feel old like I
was in love with the place that had been
forgotten and I was feeling pretty sorry
for my old ass self when I happened to
look up and see an Emily Dickinson quote
her feet on the wall apparently in
eight well you can imagine the nostalgia
Hank down there where I have loved in
law
staring down at this creek that ran
through my adolescence feeling comforted
by the knowledge that our legacy was
well maintained by the students of today
with their dick and Sounion burfi tee
and I'm walking back up at the very
pinnacle of this fit of sentimentality
and then BAM stung by a bee ah these
thing bee sting bee sting oh that hurts
Oh daddy that's always how it goes Hank
you're just trying to romanticize your
frickin past for one second and then a
frickin bee comes along and stings you
on the very top of your left butt cheek
ruining everything of course then I had
to call Sarah and tell her I'd been
stung by a bee because it is a medically
proven fact that the only thing that
lessens the pain of a bee sting is
whining to your wife
these trampolines are just close enough
to each other to invite poor decisions
and just far enough apart to punish
those poor decisions eventually I found
myself in the second place there used to
be a barn in this field a barn where I
first told a girl I loved her and where
I spent my first all-nighter studying
world history by flashlight while
drinking astonishingly bad wine Emily
Dickinson wrote that success is counted
sweetest by those who NER succeed and so
to youth is counted sweetest by those
who are no longer young nostalgia is
inevitably a yearning for a past that
never existed and when I'm riding there
are no bees to sting me out of my
sentimentality for me at least fiction
is the only way I can even begin to
twist my Lying memories into something
true Hank I'll see you on Friday